- [Instructor] The function f is defined
over the real numbers.
This table gives a few values of f.
So when x is equal to negative 4.1,
f of x is negative five.
F of negative 4.01
is negative 55,
so they give us a bunch of values
for different x's of what f of x would be.
What is a reasonable
estimate for the limit
as x approaches negative four of f of x.
So let's think about what's happening.
To think of a reasonable
estimate for the limit
as x approaches negative four,
we'd want to think about well,
what does it look like the
function is approaching
as x approaches negative four
from values less than negative four,
so that's what we have here on the table.
And then we'd also want to think about
well, what does it look like
our function is approaching
as x approaches negative four
from values greater than
negative four from the right.
So this is approaching,
this is what is f of x approaches,
x approaches negative four from the left?
This is what is f of x approaching
as x approaches negative
four from the right?
So let's think about it.
When x is negative 4.1,
we're at negative five.
Then we're at negative 4.01,
we go to negative 55.
And then when we get to negative 4.001,
so we're only 1/1000
away from negative four,
we get to negative 555.
So this just seems to get
larger and larger and larger
and then at negative
four, it's negative 5,555.
So this is interesting.
There could be a scenario
where this is getting more and,
this is getting infinitely negative
as we get close to negative four.
And that negative four then jumps back up
to negative 5,555.
Or this is a situation where
we are at negative four.
We're just kind of approaching
this value right over here.
It's unclear based on the
information in the table.
Now let's think about what's happening
as we approach from the right.
So at negative 3.9, we're at five.
Negative 3.99, we're at 55.
Negative 3.999, we go to 555.
So this seems to be getting larger
and as we get closer and
closer to negative four
as x gets closer and closer to
negative four from the right,
it looks like f of x is getting larger
and larger and larger.
It's not going more and more negative.
So as I mentioned if you
wanted to think about scenarios
of what might be happening here,
we don't know for sure because remember
when we're using a table
we're just taking samples.
So let me let me draw what
could be happening here.
Once again, we don't know
for sure just by sampling.
But once again, they just want us to get
a reasonable estimate.
So that's the x-axis
and that is the y-axis.
And we care about x equals negative four.
So let's say that this is
this is x equals negative
four right over here,
x equals negative four.
So there's a couple of scenarios.
There's one scenario where
it's doing something like this,
where it's doing something like this,
where it's just going to negative 5,555
and so this isn't at the same scale.
So there's this scenario
where this right over here
is negative 5,555.
But then from the right,
you're doing something
completely different,
or not completely different,
you're going in the opposite direction.
So from the right, it looks like this.
You're just getting larger
and larger and larger,
just getting more and
more and more and more.
I guess as you get closer
and closer to negative four
from the right
maybe you're going to positive infinity
or maybe you're going to,
well we don't know based on this data.
It looks like it could just be
going unbounded to positive infinity
and then right at negative four
you go to negative 5,555.
In this situation, you would have no limit
at x equals negative four.
Even though the function is defined there,
you would have no limit,
because when you approach from the right,
you're going to positive infinity.
When you approach from the left,
you're either going to negative infinity
or you're going to the
value negative 5,555.
Another scenario that might be happening
as we approach from the left
might be something like this.
It might be approaching,
it might be approaching negative infinity.
And then you just jump back up
to this value right over here.
So let me erase this
one just so you can see
what I'm talking about.
So this is another scenario
that right at negative four,
so from either side it looks like you are,
you have an asymptote going on.
So from either side you have
this vertical asymptote right over here.
So as you approach from the left,
you're going to negative infinity.
As you approach from the right,
you're going to positive infinity,
but right at negative four,
you're defined at this value.
So this is another possibility.
But in this case as well,
there's no limit here.
You're not approaching
the same finite value
from both sides.
Now one thing that you'll sometimes see is
if people think that okay,
if you're approaching the same,
either from both sides you're
approaching positive infinity
or from both sides you're
approaching negative infinity.
Sometimes people say, "Oh
my limit is infinity."
Or "My limit is negative infinity."
So let's say you have
a situation like this
where from, at some value,
and you're think about
the limit as you approach,
as x approaches that value,
as you approach from either side,
you're going to positive infinity.
Well formerly you still wouldn't
say the limit is infinity,
because a limit formally is a finite value
that you are actually approaching.
So in any of these scenarios,
especially the scenario that we see here
where you're going to
positive infinity here,
negative infinity,
or you're going to negative 5,555 here,
the limit does not exist.
So let me just circle that.